where I just I just wrote the greatest
hip-hop song of all time for me
so he's shy
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
everybody's got their own process of
writing books Stefan I have ours mine is
really like you know you know I have to
hear it or read it edit it step screen
framework coming from all my content got
to make it my words this is how I do it
question was much more your the coffee
King like I'm the wine king right so
just want to put a book want to pound
that home all the way through you are
the business where you are the CEO of a
business that builds brand and it
siphons their business which is much
more me you know not like this I mean I
didn't even know the word existed I'm
just kidding 17 19 years old selling
baseball cards doing stuff and I use the
word businessman that word was terrible
like the few times you ever heard it it
was like the rich kid having like a
business card like doing nothing like it
was like I'm an entrepreneur you know
what's funny I realized why the world
was in a bad place but there's about to
go into a bad place again all these kids
that are putting over an entrepreneur in
their Instagram profile aren't
entrepreneurs they want to be
entrepreneurs the word for some reason
gets manifested in a negative way hey
hey oh really Wow real pleasure man how
are you Rachel I'm doing good let you
smell good thank you after IV shower any
shape or no similarity is that right
yeah wrong up that way I'm always every
time you get a chance to choose from
jingle reading like elementary school
take an addict I love that yeah I love
that
okay all right you know this you know I
was but
to see what happens what about this is
keep going rapid-fire yeah that's so
looking crazy it's document over
creating that's what it is yeah it's
just value like if you like if you're
good enough it will happen like you
flat-out wouldn't them made it 20 years
ago yeah like like chance like I mean it
like it was just too many gatekeepers
and now the markets the gatekeeper the
Internet's the middleman and now it's
holding people back is they're using the
old model right they think they got to
put out an album every three years
they need to be putting out a [ __ ]
song every day now you may not be good
enough to put out a song every day but
if you're good enough to put a song out
every other day then that's what you do
and if you're not good enough to do that
you put out a song every three days if
you're not going to do that like but
whatever it is you got to put out those
songs do Princes seven best songs of all
time never made it to the world well no
I don't know but I know this exact
that's the point the point is Michael
Jackson's six biggest hits we're like
yeah let's not put that on the album
that's it not number one raps on the
country right now no really that's it
and that's the thing that I'm going to
tell my grandkids that changes their
lives might have just happened here but
if I didn't have the rock it would have
never happened
yeah like the seven best things Martin
Luther King said the nineteen most
clever things that Muhammad Ali said the
the thing that Madonna thought about how
she was going to build her brand all
lost in time lost in time lost in time
and is it weirdest luck to have two
human beings in the room does be filming
yes but that's only weird now because
guess what there'd be four people in
here at booth filming in two years and
it's just the way it is just as weird as
[ __ ] taking a selfie on every single
case like people didn't take pictures
that are food twenty years ago a super
Newark seems super normal now it's real
cool man I love it thanks you know what
makes me happy makes me optimistic makes
me feel like we've never lived in a
world where
the truth is one more and it's the
internet people can blame the internet
for so much bad it's so good it allows
the truth like guess what there's a
bunch of kids are going to watch this
log right bunch in little Kyle's right
and then then put out 365 songs they're
gonna watch it this is a good moment
like I put 365 songs for four years in a
row and nothing is going to happen
because they weren't good enough it's
not that everybody gets to win it's just
that the winners get to win but you know
but like if you set you listen people
sit there and see their contemporaries
go and they and you felt it you felt
like am I should be there and how the
Internet's the answer SoundCloud the
answer spotlight the answers iTunes the
answer blogs are the answer DMing meet
dee dee rock on Instagram to get your
song on daily be the answer every single
rapper every single artist should
literally DM ever an email a message
every single vlogger that has a hundred
thousand views per video in the world
and give them free music to put in their
vlogs yeah yeah you got away right its
distribution now the song sucks
nothing's going to happen so why didn't
you guys almost put out the song um well
you know what the yachty doesn't agree
because it was written we all agree on
it already or you guys had a first one
in they got into me so you wait but
that's just stupid I would've fired you
when you yell
you know I was being like housing are
you were being fancying that house being
fancy no not always can we do the--can
do me a favor Eddie do me a favor can we
can we can we make a custom shirt from a
medium or large good make me a medium
shirt I don't want to say stop being
fancy and I'm setting it to him what you
know what that's what we start doing
actually I just made up something with
all my shirts I'm going to start making
one offs one one-of-a-kind with the
signature like part of the line of the
shirts I've got but one off when I feel
it I'm giving you the first one and
because they stopped being fancy you're
going to wear once in a while hmm
because it's important you know why it's
binary
you are just talented you can't judge
yourself just put it out let them judge
you might not like it now you might be
we're just talking this Stephanie land
she helps me go straight my books we're
writing we're running the next book
called crushed it right or crushing
we're trying to figure out but like you
know like you can't judge it like right
like my favorite book is Thank You
economy like I'm fancy about it but the
market took it differently maybe they
can get it maybe I didn't do a good job
I also didn't market it the way market
is every other book because I was real
busy building the foundation of
vaynermedia but like I promise you
you'll put our song next week and it
won't do well and like by what your new
standards right you'll do fine but you
might love it the most 17 years later
yeah like what are gonna do with it the
[ __ ] was your playing with the song you
made it the hell are you gonna do with
it
just keep it on a drive oh you guys you
know and you know that you do you make
it you make a good point because I feel
you even back then I think
only thing keeping me from putting it
out exactly Oh back in the day sorry
bangers every come here
yeah back in the day 2014 I mean no
anything right evening me for like that
is your right this right content and
just like releasing the song if I read
it release the song we just put the [ __ ]
out what for now once you stop worrying
about what everybody says for real yeah
for real
and I mean your friend from around the
way and Jesus and and XXL and Boyd and
like anybody once you actually go there
and you just make a binary decision that
I'm an artist and I believe in my stuff
and it's all my stuff the good the bad
and ugly then it's game over
yeah now in fact you're really making
really good job knowledge because yeah
that song too with by artists I was
working to put it out because I wanted
to do something that was more like
artistic of course or and you know what
that P ready minute is one article to me
that I rented out for it was Pharrell
and I'm feeling I read that right before
we started putting up these songs with
everyone and I was just talking about
like not being extra attached to your
music like people I love your music love
making regular people like see their
music as themselves and so they they are
so worried about putting it out and they
always want to make sure that it's a hit
and then just trying to change the set
but you know what's funny you make new
that people make it people will
determine something in the smash it you
just made music meaning soldiers made it
you know what I actually fully believe
in that slightly in Reverse I think it's
not that you how'd you say it don't get
to read will go be like so I know
interfaces whatever right so I think
it's the reverse
I think it's be so attached to yourself
that you know every piece is great yeah
so I don't I don't create everything and
put my life on blast because I'm not
worried about it it's because I'm so
bought in that I feel it's all great it
may not do well by people making hits
he's right about that I don't know what
videos going to necessarily go viral
except one so I'm like this is gonna go
viral I'm does but but but I thought
that thing the other day in the car
right looks gonna fit like 55 you're
like like not everything goes and
and I remember I don't dwell it I don't
even think about it so I think it's
actually the reverse which is like you
should really care about it you just
love all of it and just go yeah I also
think what's crazy though people don't
think about music like I think about
Google I didn't even put out a song next
week that doesn't pop that could really
pop five years from now cuz some little
girl puts it on her musically said she
just happens to be the number one person
she stumbled on it cuz she she was
laying in her bed thinking of hopscotch
she googled hop scotch your song came up
because you put in that lyric she
listens she loves it
she lips it you did it in 2018 she made
it pop in 2023 yeah crazy on keep silent
no two instances of that kind of
happening you remember the song for my
ugly for better vision or hear of course
that's always hello that's always like
here will not help not in 10 years over
one years old and because of a so
bindable
fluffy abyss yeah I remember kpop again
I remember the song called don't drop
that under that I went crazy being like
ringing others I got lucky my boo spoke
yeah because that's by the way that was
a theory I had forever and when I saw
that happen I'm like that's it lock it
wait that's dangerous no sucked about
yeah doesn't know because it went to
number 5 on the [ __ ] iTunes chart and
it was a jerking song yeah yeah and so
when twerking happened that was what
happened when twerking went crazy and
buying well it was out there was a thing
called memory George a it was a dance
craze called all that and it was from
the drinking era like when I was like 15
going and house parties we're listen to
don't drop
in there and then [ __ ] five years
later however many years later
that [ __ ] was cracking again and and
what else is crazy is if your it looks
like you know look this is what's just
happening with you now it's like this
you guys I mean it's funny I can't
imagine what's happening now with you
guys like when you have that moment it's
crazy
like right you're just waking we clear
making like it just weird like it we're
more or less like like walking down the
street and hearing your song by in
somebody's car I don't even know how you
like I would lose my [ __ ] have a
question yeah like speed of content
versus quality speed why cuz quality
subjective dares yeah speed actually
with you eat isn't yeah yeah like it's
at bar you like his hat wait to you yeah
you silly say no if that's the punch
yeah yeah the punch lines you almost
didn't put up the song yeah speed speed
what's so funny because now now that we
have a hit we're like now what right
because a little bit of that how do we
slow down or do you keep going in here
the thing is what guys here we're doing
this once on a month and not on the
course stay the course now that you got
eyes on you you have percent they're
gonna like it by default you put out a
song the song you put out next week if
you put out that song four months ago
it would have been a four let's say
before let's say that where it's not
subjected is the music God and he it
comes because that feels like it's all
subjective but let's just make the
center fun there's a music God and you
put out this on and she goes for it's a
for she says it's a four it was four
months ago you wouldn't put it out it
would have been a four but now after a
song it's a seven yeah yeah do you know
we force ourselves to like the songs the
people we've decided the biggest people
in the world yes it's true because as
we're like all looking at up-and-coming
when he sends me eight links of
up-and-comers and I'm just listening if
I don't like it the first time I don't
like it the first time if it's Drake I'm
like are lumison just 15 more times it's
not you
it'll grow on you
put out a lot ASAT yeah damn alright my
ballon [ __ ] we're gonna get on that
mistake coming through like just put
something out yeah you right yeah or do
you like go in and just do it no I did
you right good so ready ready on a very
serious note the number one thing you
should put out next this is such a Miss
by artist if something just happened
I'll help you I'm coming right back
it just happened yeah right it they know
what you're talking about
if you have it just happened like
[ __ ] rind some [ __ ] with the quote in
the high school thing like tell me tell
me why it happened because your dad [ __ ]
you just wrote the song with me right
now tell me about your dad's blind
confidence that it just happened because
all of you just heard me for the first
time because that's your next song yeah
you know why Wow yeah that's how people
fall in line laughing why did that just
happen right about that yeah Wow guys I
would be the biggest artist in the world
do you understand yes because I just
heard it if you're the next song is how
you got here that's the story yeah
that's what everybody's trying to figure
out who you are right now tell him that
will be a monster yeah yeah you know why
I like Trey because he told me so I like
hip-hop they tell me the stories
everybody loves the origin story it's a
comic clarity got here that's my comic
books are timeless that's what I want to
know tell me how you felt salty when all
of them popped and how you're like
sitting by the punch bowls crying
I think it's a really big idea I think
it's how you make your second songs over
in the first one yeah
because because you've got curiosity and
how you seal it is by backing it up like
the narrative let's just tell the truth
the truth always wins
don't the key now is to not embellish it
to just write it as it is like I wish my
entrepreneurial story had some other
stories I mean lemonade stands are cool
like baseball cards are cool like stock
boy liquor sorts cool everybody thinks
it's cooler now you think it's cooler
now but it shall not that great like
three stories like but but once you so
like can other people care and you're
telling it it's just cooler because
they're like I didn't you only kids in
it like now all about you cuz a song and
they're like yeah that happened to me
too because it's a real story that
happens real people mm-hmm I know I'm
right I know that justice I know that
when you have the cut this moment the
way to explode it is to write the story
of how it just happened you know like
turn it back to like not being an artist
for like listening to enough music it's
like like if you come out the gate and
just saying you just heard me but I've
been hearing myself the whole time
that's just powerful yeah yeah it's very
true so handle there may be a camera
thank you I'm gonna figure this out yeah
like right like I think like if I heard
that and I know that everybody hears the
new one and like that's the opening
framework yeah yeah well he yeah well I
just I just wrote the greatest hip-hop
song of all time for me
so he's a shout out
thank you so much for your signal class
because really come together to
celebrate ah sorry I know it's gonna be
a little windy here I'm getting into a
car I think you and I share DNA right
you lie the why is that because there's
no choice right so why is I have no
choice if it picked you it picked me
it picked others high-energy optimistic
ambitious entrepreneurial storyteller
you don't really pick the Y the Y picks
you and so the insanity is the sanity
right like I don't know man that's just
just it's just who I am
it's what I do and and I just think that
I got lucky and blessed with the right
circumstances being an immigrant from
the former Soviet Union growing up in
Jersey with East Coast flavor picking
the wrong New York teams so that I'm
only sad and hungry and have a chip on
my shoulder a lot of things have gone in
my favor
so I'm gonna going into a client meeting
with uh with a client that we've been
working with it's very senior that this
is my first meeting with them which is
always a fun and unusual situation
because I'm a character and my team is
uh so great at what they do and it's
always funny when I get introduced into
a relationship as you can imagine either
a home run or a ho note a home run or us
not a strikeout anymore because I'm you
know at a point of my career where I
have a lot of empathy um wonder if I
understand like vaynermedia the
customers right like I'm walking in
there and um I'm an employee of that you
know like their mom I'm servicing she
and he is the boss like I feel very
bossy for Vayner but for my clients
they're the boss I've got passionate
points of view that I won't waver on and
that's why they should hire me and
that's why they should work with me
because I'm not gonna yes them for a
couple of more dollars I don't need
their dollars but I'm going to respect
the [ __ ] out of them and I know my role
I stay in my lane when I'm onstage it's
my stage when I'm in a client meeting
it's their business and I'm
to influence what they do because I
think I'm great at what I do and it can
help them sell more stuff achieve more
things that they're trying to achieve
but when they say no or they push back I
don't think they're dumb or they suck I
think they're navigating their business
what I do that no because I always give
advice that I believe in but they're
navigating their business and there's a
lot of people have intermedia that you
can learn that our clients don't not get
it they're just running their [ __ ] and
and when I say vaynermedia I mean
everybody who services a business every
agency every service provider like the
decision makers the decision maker the
customer is right because the right for
themselves doesn't mean that you have to
waver but it needs that means that you
have to respect and I walk in there with
all my confidence bravado strategy and
skills and a whole lot of humility
empathy and reality all mixed into one
randomly
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean what really well real progress
smart people are smart let's love smart
client makes it a lot better a lot
easier to win that is a real challenge
of not being in B debate you're at the
mercy of the decision maker on the other
side when you're b2c you go directly to
the consumer and the market is the
market it feels easier and and more pure
to me
BB's been a fun challenge learning as
well we're like you're going to lose on
human ridiculousness
where people aren't making decisions in
the best interest of the business which
is unusual for me I'm coming from a
family business that's the only thing
that one is trying to do and it has its
own shortcomings but when it's good it's
good get a smart client you can make a
real impact
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what they don't understand is that my
complete belief and this is back to a
bigger more theoretical version of if
you're in it for cars and [ __ ]
watches you're finished it's not human
to be 100% Southwest [ __ ] you no reason
you know that's right but you know it's
the only reason I think I'm so much
bigger is I'm so obsessed with my legacy
now I'm going to give it all I don't
need anything except I want it all in
the afterlife which but in a real way
like I'm obsessed with my legacy I want
it to be all time which is why I
communicate and produce so much and live
the way I live day to day which is what
makes everybody like me it's important
it's how I got here I couldn't get here
without it
I didn't have any other way to get here
without having that disproportional
leverage of not caring I never have
about the melt it just I I didn't care
about the money I was making $42,000 a
year to my campaign myself $42,000 a
year if I cared about it I've I've taken
it to minutes right
you know what I mean it's important and
it's a fun conversation because it's a
very important theme to how somebody
actually crushes it it's the truth of
the good you know it just is and there's
always those answers you know and I feel
they're the right answer so it's winner
fun to be fair no no not to be fair it's
how I got it I know how I got it I also
know how much I had left it's a very
important theme for this the real
opportunity you know off the platform I
have now it's a real opportunity it's
these things even with the people that
know me well know me the best know me
kind of it's these conversations that
that are taking me to the my next place
you know it's cool right it's an
interesting insight that we have to
really find here because I think it
takes the people that are cynical not
sure curious it gives them what they
need to be like what I'm doing this for
them I'm ramping you right now because I
know how many people going to read this
that is going to be told to read it
they're gonna be like uh
he's just another one of those guys
right here this another like [ __ ]
[Music]